Die Schweiz -
ein Land, in dem man gerne lebt.
Ein Land,
in dem eigentlich alles funktioniert.
Prochain arrêt: Lausanne. Bonjour.
Viele Menschen
tragen im Hintergrund dazu bei.
Canad Cali fährt mit dem Postauto
in die hintersten Täler des Tessins.
Denise Schöni betreut
in der Region Biel kranke Kinder.
Roger Siegenthaler
ist Kranführer im Berner Oberland.
Und Maëlle Bertarionne
arbeitete in der Uhrenindustrie
und hat sich nach der Kündigung
selbstständig gemacht.
Wie leben diese Menschen?
Wofür setzen sie sich ein?
Und was beschäftigt sie?
Vier Menschen und ihr Alltag -
ein Tag im Leben der Schweiz.
Gordola im Tessin, es ist 4.30 Uhr.
Der 26-jährige Canad hat Frühdienst.
Er ist
mit einer Tessinerin verheiratet.
Meine Frau ist nicht da.
Gestern Abend
ist sie zu ihren Eltern gegangen,
und sie wird
bis Samstagmorgen dort bleiben.
Sie wohnen nicht
so weit von uns entfernt,
in den oberen Bergen.
Ich bin ganz allein.
Das mag er nicht.
Es weckt Erinnerungen
ans Waisenhaus in Somalia,
in dem er aufgewachsen ist.
Zur gleichen Zeit auf
der anderen Seite der Alpen, in Thun.
Der 36-jährige Roger
ist ebenfalls früh auf.
Wenn ich betonieren muss,
nehme ich nie
etwas Warmes zu essen mit.
Beim Betonieren
kann immer etwas passieren.
Manchmal ist es nicht garantiert,
dass ich meine Mittagspause habe.
Darum bereite ich mir jetzt
ein Znüni-Brötchen zu,
und am Mittag gönne ich mir dann
zwei Brötchen aus der Tankstelle.
Alles sonst im Haushalt
macht seine Frau.
Sie und die zwei Kinder
schlafen noch.
Canad muss sein Postauto in Spruga
im hintersten Winkel
des Onsernonetals holen.
Im Radio läuft die Landeshymne.
Letztes Jahr
wurde der Somalier eingebürgert.
* Instrumentalversion
des Schweizerpsalms *
Ich vertrete beide Länder.
Aber ich habe meine Kindheit
in Somalia verbracht, bis 15.
Und ich wohne seit zehn Jahren hier.
Vielleicht werde ich  mehrere Jahre
hier verbringen, 20 Jahre oder so.
Aber ich habe
15 Jahre in Somalia verbracht,
und diese sind wertvoller.
Ich weiss nicht warum.
Das ist ein Hirsch. Nein.
Ja, ja, das ist ein Hirsch.
Ein ganzes Rudel.
* Instrumentalversion
des Schweizerpsalms *
Es ist 6 Uhr im Berner Oberland.
Roger ist im Werkhof angekommen.
Seit zwei Jahren
arbeitet er für diese Baufirma.
Endlich hat er seinen Platz gefunden.
Er ist immer früher hier,
als er müsste.
Meine Kollegen
schauen mich immer blöd an
und fragen:
"Schläfst du denn nicht?"
Und ich sage: "Nein,
das ist einfach meine Zeit:
keine Frau, keine Kinder,
einfach ganz alleine und gut ist."
Morgen, Toni.
Roger war ein schlechter Schüler
und hat seine Lehre als Zimmermann
nur knapp geschafft.
Nachher
hat er als Handlanger gearbeitet,
bis er durch einen glücklichen Zufall
eine Ausbildung zum Kranführer
machen konnte.
Bellmund in der Nähe von Biel.
Es ist 6.30 Uhr.
Die 46-jährige Denise lebt mit ihrem
Partner und ihren zwei Kindern hier.
Der Morgen
ist nicht ihre bevorzugte Tageszeit.
Guten Morgen.
Was machst du wieder hier oben?
* Genervtes Seufzen *
Das ist mein Platz.
- Ja, genau.
Du weisst ganz genau,
dass du da nichts zu suchen hast.
Ihre Tochter Jasmine besucht
die letzte Klasse der Oberstufe.
Der Sohnemann hat wie immer
eine Sauerei hinterlassen.
Die zwei Hauptthemen am Morgen
sind, wie in den meisten Familien mit
Teenagern, die Ordnung und das Handy.
Wir haben wenigstens erreicht, dass
die Handys abends hier unten sind.
Sie werden eingesteckt
und schlafen quasi hier unten.
Am Morgen
werden sie wieder eingeschaltet.
Wenn sie früher wach ist als ich,
dann kommt es darauf an,
wie fit ich bin und ob ich
Lust habe, aufzustehen oder nicht.
Wenn ich Nachtwache mache,
bin ich froh,
wenn ich am Morgen
noch etwas länger schlafen kann.
Die Männer in der Familie
stehen früher auf.
Sohn Simon macht eine Schreinerlehre
und Partner Stefan ist Ofenmonteur.
Denise arbeitet bei der Kinderspitex.
Die ausgebildete
Kinderkrankenschwester
kann sich die Zeit
relativ frei einteilen.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Tschüss.
- Du nimmst ja den Bus, stimmt.
Um die gleiche Zeit im abgelegenen
Brot-Plamboz im Neuenburger Jura.
Maëlle ist Graveurin.
Ich trage nicht unbedingt Make-up,
wenn ich weiss,
dass ich den ganzen Tag
in der Werkstatt bin.
Wenn ich niemanden sehe
und nirgendwohin gehe,
mache ich mir diese Mühe nicht.
Aber ansonsten
trage ich gerade genug,
um ein wenig wach auszusehen.
Voilà.
Sie lebt mit ihrem Freund
seit drei Jahren in diesem Haus
und arbeitet zu Hause.
Wenn ich um 6 Uhr aufstehe, kann ich
um 6.30 Uhr an meinem Tisch sein.
Ich verliere keine Zeit,
keine Fahrt, kein Parken.
Aus all diesen Gründen ist es
sehr, sehr bequem, finde ich.
So ganz freiwillig hat Maëlle das
allerdings nicht gewählt.
Sie hat 15 Jahre lang
in der Uhrenindustrie gearbeitet,
wurde aber vor einem Jahr wegen
einer Restrukturierung entlassen.
Jetzt versucht sie's
als Selbstständige.
Das ist ein ziemlich massiver Ring.
Da steht Yasta drauf,
im Hip-Hop-Stil.
Diese Schrift, Chevallier New Style,
habe ich noch nie gemacht,
sie ist cool.
(Elektronische Frauenstimme)
Loco, Chiesa.
340 km entfernt um die gleiche Zeit.
Buongiorno.
- Buongiorno.
Langsam
füllt sich im Onsernonetal der Bus.
Seit zwei Jahren
ist Canad bei der Post.
Dem gelernten Lastwagenfahrer
macht es Spass,
sein Postauto durch die engen
Strassen des Tals zu steuern.
Ich halte mich für einen Glückspilz.
Für mich ist es
nicht nur eine Arbeit, es ist mehr.
Die Schweiz hat eines
der dichtesten ÖV-Netze der Welt.
Es gibt fast 12'000
Postauto-Haltestellen
und mit 2'300 Fahrzeugen
befördert die Post
rund 155 Mio. Fahrgäste pro Jahr.
Ankunft in Locarno, es ist 6.57 Uhr.
Arrivederci. Ciao, ciao.
Die Fahrgäste
sind fast immer dieselben:
Leute, die zur Arbeit
und zur Schule gehen.
Als Canad in die Schweiz kam, wurde
er von Vallorbe nach Chiasso verlegt.
Das war vor zehn Jahren.
Mittlerweile
hat er sich gut integriert.
Aber ein Buschauffeur aus Somalia,
das war schon ungewohnt hier.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie sie reagiert haben,
aber sie haben mir
viele Fragen gestellt:
wann ich angefangen habe,
woher ich komme,
wieso ich ins Tal gekommen bin.
Diese Sachen halt.
Sie haben positiv reagiert,
sagen wir mal. Schön.
Rogers Kran ist 35 m hoch.
Es lohnt sich,
vor dem Aufstieg zu überlegen,
ob man etwas vergessen hat.
Seine Baustelle liegt bei Oberried
am Brienzersee. Es ist 8 Uhr.
Ich sage immer,
das sei meine Einzimmerwohnung.
Hier bin ich ein bisschen der Chef.
Ich sage auch mal,
wie man vielleicht etwas machen
oder organisieren könnte.
Ich sitze ja hier, sehe über alles
und sehe vielleicht Sachen,
die man unten nicht sieht.
Jetzt sehen wir eben,
dass etwas nicht passt,
da müssen sie
noch etwas präparieren.
Roger hat seine Berufung gefunden.
Ich lebe für diesen Job.
Ich würde für kein Geld ...
Wenn jetzt einer kommen
und sagen würde, ich bekäme 1 Mio.,
würde ich sagen: "Nein, vergiss es!"
Ich mache diesen Job zu gerne,
ich bin zu gerne
auf der Baustelle bei den Leuten.
Inzwischen
ist auch seine Familie wach.
Guten Morgen.
Hallo, Leandro.
- Hallo.
Guten Appetit.
Bist du beim Frühstück?
Ja.
Schmeckt es?
Schau mal, was Papi macht.
Hier.
Hast du einen Kran gebaut? Super.
Ich schaue nachher.
Ich muss kurz was machen.
Manchmal muss ich auch sagen:
"Jetzt musst du schnell warten,
ich kann gerade nicht schauen",
so wie jetzt.
(Frau) Tschüss, Papi.
- Tschüss, Mami.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
(Mann über Funk)
Roger, du kannst hochziehen.
Zurück am Bielersee.
Denise hat ihren ersten Termin
um 9 Uhr.
Zeit, sich vorher noch
um den Haushalt zu kümmern.
Die Aargauerin ist ursprünglich
wegen des Vaters ihrer Kinder
in den Kanton Bern gezogen.
Vor zwölf Jahren
hat sie sich aber von ihm getrennt.
Ich war auch
eine Zeit lang alleinerziehend,
das ist nicht immer lustig.
V.a. ist man immer die Böse.
Man kann es nie abgeben,
auch wenn man manchmal nicht mag.
Und ja, manchmal mag man
halt einfach nicht mehr
immer alles alleine stemmen.
Sieben Jahre war sie allein,
bis das Schicksal sie zu einem
alten Bekannten zurückgeführt hat.
Ja, das ging um sieben Ecken.
Ursprünglich
kennen wir uns von früher.
Er ist im gleichen Dorf aufgewachsen
wie ich.
Eigentlich
hat mich eine gute Freundin
auf eine Datingseite
im Internet geschickt.
Dort bin ich über ihn gestolpert
und habe ihn angeschrieben,
ob er sich noch an mich erinnerte.
Und dann hat man sich getroffen
und dann ... ist das so entstanden.
Ja, und dann ist er
relativ bald mal bei uns eingezogen.
Jedes sechste Paar in der Schweiz
lernt sich mittlerweile
übers Internet kennen.
Die Dunkelziffer ist natürlich gross.
Nicht immer einfach,
wenn ein neuer Mann ins Haus kommt.
Wie hat das funktioniert?
Stefan ist eine Art Papi-Ersatz
für die Kinder,
obwohl sie mit ihrem Vater
sporadisch Kontakt haben,
aber er ist immer da.
Canad ist wieder auf dem Weg
nach Spruga. Es ist 8.30 Uhr.
Er hat seine Frau über
eine Asylorganisation kennengelernt.
Seit vier Jahren
sind sie verheiratet.
Nie hätte er gedacht, dass er
einmal im Onsernonetal landen würde.
È il tuo turno, dai.
Via allora!
(Mann im Radio) La situazione
è di 2:2 nel confronto.
Meine Reise hat in Somalia begonnen.
Ich bin durch viele Länder gereist:
Kenia, Uganda, Südsudan, Libyen.
Dann habe ich
die Migrationsroute genommen
und bin nach Frankreich gegangen
und von dort in die Schweiz.
Mein Ziel war es,
in ein sicheres Land auszuwandern,
wo ich mich integrieren
und ruhig sein kann.
Hier im Tal fühle ich mich gut,
hier gibt es weniger Probleme.
* Postauto-Hupe *
* Lockere Klänge *
Er war noch fast ein Kind,
als er aus Mogadischu geflüchtet ist.
Letztes Jahr ist Canad erstmals
wieder in seine Heimat zurückgekehrt.
Mogadischu liegt am Meer.
Wir sind in den Bergen,
auf 1'100 m Höhe.
Es ist ganz anders.
Letztes Jahr
bin ich nach Somalia gegangen,
und nach nur zwei Wochen
vermisste ich die Berge.
Das Brot für diesen Laden,
der Laden von Spruga.
Es ist wichtig,
dass wir das Brot bringen.
Wir lassen es hier.
Wenn der Besitzer kommt,
wird er es sehen.
Das ist ein Dienst,
den wir anbieten.
Wir tragen auch
Brot und Zeitungen aus.
Um dieselbe Zeit im Neuenburger Jura.
Maëlle arbeitet still vor sich hin.
Ihre einzige Begleitung
ist das Radio.
Oh, mais j'ai pas l'air.
Als Selbstständige
sind wir unsere schlimmsten Feinde,
denn wir üben Druck
auf uns selbst aus,
obwohl es nicht unbedingt
notwendig ist.
Solange es Arbeit gibt
und wir in Bewegung sind,
haben wir keine Zeit für Stress,
es geht uns gut.
Aber plötzlich gibt es Momente,
da beginnt die Paranoia
und sie fängt an, sich mit
voller Geschwindigkeit zu drehen,
und dann muss man etwas tun,
um sie aufzuhalten.
Man muss eine heisse Dusche nehmen
oder stricken
oder in den Garten gehen,
um Unkraut zu jäten,
und dann geht es von selbst vorbei.
Es ist kurz vor 9 Uhr.
Denise ist auf dem Weg
zu ihrem ersten Patienten.
Sie arbeitet seit über zehn Jahren
für die Kinderspitex.
Ich arbeite gerne selbstständig.
Ich glaube, sonst würde ich es
nicht schon so lange machen.
Wenn immer möglich, betreut sie
die kranken Kinder über längere Zeit.
Hallo, hallo. Hoi, Luca.
Es sind schöne Momente, wenn du
mit den Kindern am Arbeiten bist,
und sie dich anstrahlen
oder sie mit dir quasseln.
Ja, ich denke, wenn du merkst,
dass die Harmonie stimmt,
das sind sehr schöne Momente.
Einfach auch die Dankbarkeit
zu spüren für das, was du machst.
Aber es ist nicht immer einfach.
Levin hat die Lungenkrankheit
Cystische Fibrose
und muss täglich zweimal inhalieren.
Das findet er meistens nicht so toll.
Du bist ein schwieriger Fall.
Eine schwierige Phase.
Sie wachsen natürlich
da hinein und damit auf.
Es gibt Phasen,
in denen es besser geht,
und solche,
in denen es weniger gut geht.
Aber wichtig ist es für die Lunge,
dass sie möglichst lange
möglichst gesund bleibt.
Cystische Fibrose
ist eine Erbkrankheit.
Levins Mutter wusste,
dass ein gewisses Risiko besteht.
Ich bin schon mit dem aufgewachsen,
mit dieser Krankheit,
und kenne eigentlich
den Alltag mit CF.
Meine Schwester hat schon CF.
Dadurch kenne ich es
auch nicht anders.
Das macht es vielleicht einfacher.
* Leises Kinderlied: "ABC Lied" *
* Luca quasselt. *
Taaa.
Am Brienzersee. Roger macht Pause.
Es lohnt sich nicht, runterzugehen
und nachher wieder rauf.
Auch wenn wir jetzt
30 Min. Znünipause haben.
Man darf eben nicht vergessen:
In der Regel
haben wir nur 15 Min. Znünipause.
Wenn es ein bisschen länger geht,
wie jetzt, sind schnell 5 Min. um.
Dann hab ich noch 10 Min. Pause,
dann geht es schon wieder weiter.
Roger gilt als "Gmüetsmohre"
und überaus liebenswürdiger
und hilfsbereiter Kumpel.
Er lässt alle leben, so wie sie sind.
Fast zwei Drittel aller Arbeitskräfte
auf den Schweizer Baustellen
sind Ausländer.
Damit hat er überhaupt kein Problem.
Wir haben Ausländer,
aber die sind
schon seit Jahren in der Schweiz
und gehören
in dem Sinne auch zu uns.
Eine Zeit lang
haben wir es schon gemerkt,
da die billigeren Arbeitskräfte,
die reinkommen ...
Ja, es geht hier
einfach Arbeit verloren,
wenn eine Firma
andere Preise machen kann,
weil sie solche Leute einstellt,
die fast nichts verdienen.
Manchmal mache ich mir schon
ein bisschen Sorgen.
Wenn du zu Hause
eine Frau und zwei Kinder hast
und irgendwann
nicht mehr garantieren kannst,
dass sie immer etwas zu Essen haben.
Dass sich das mal ...
- (Mann über Funk) Roger.
Sorgen ...
... muss man schon ein bisschen
haben in der heutigen Zeit.
Alles geht so schnell.
Dann liest man wieder:
"Da werden 100 Jobs gestrichen,
hier geht eine Firma zu ..."
Roger stammt aus schwierigen,
ärmlichen Familienverhältnissen
und hat erstmals in seinem Leben
eine stabile Situation.
Kein Wunder, hat er manchmal Angst.
Canad fährt wieder los.
Obwohl er seinen Job liebt,
sein Traum wäre eigentlich
ein anderer gewesen.
Ich wollte
Maschinenbauingenieur werden,
aber bis heute
habe ich es nicht geschafft.
Nun hat er aber ein neues Ziel.
Seine letztjährige Reise nach Somalia
hat ihn inspiriert.
Er will
etwas für sein Heimatland tun.
Ich bin Somalier, und ich will
meine Herkunft nicht vergessen.
Hier in der Schweiz
fühle ich mich gut.
Ich arbeite, ich verdiene Geld,
ich habe eine schöne Frau,
ein schönes Haus
und ich habe keine Sorgen.
Den Rest könnte ich vergessen.
Ich könnte wie die anderen an schöne
Orte reisen, um mich zu erholen.
Ich gehe nach Somalia,
um meinem Volk zu helfen.
Er hat einen kleinen Verein gegründet
und sammelt Geld.
In Bellmund
nutzt Denise eine kleine Pause,
um das Mittagessen vorzubereiten.
Ihr Dienst
sieht jeden Tag anders aus.
Durchschnittlich arbeitet sie 60 %
und bringt gut
alles aneinander vorbei.
Ich liebe es, wenn viel los ist.
Und ja,
ich bin wirklich zufriedener,
wenn ich arbeiten und alles
mit der Arbeit verbinden kann.
Langsam wird es auch einfacher.
Normalerweise kommt nur noch
Jasmine zum Mittagessen heim.
Denise muss nach Biel.
Die Kinderspitex in ihrer Region
hat 17 Mitarbeiterinnen,
gesamtschweizerisch sind es etwa 600,
die sich
um rund 2'000 Kinder kümmern.
Tipptopp, sie haben uns
einen Parkplatz reserviert.
Kinderspitexdienste
sind durch die Grundversicherung
oder die IV gedeckt,
wie bei den Erwachsenen auch.
Sali. Hallo. Du bist so
ein Freundlicher. Komm mal zu mir.
Leonard ist elf Monate alt und
wird tagsüber in einem Hort betreut.
Denise muss ihm seine Medikamente
über eine Magensonde geben.
Dafür will die Hortleitung
keine Verantwortung übernehmen.
Ja, das hat natürlich
Sicherheitsaspekte.
Verantwortung tragen für das ...
Sie müssten ja auch
beurteilen können, ob alles gut ist.
Das wollten sie einfach
nicht machen, darum machen wir es.
Denise hat jeden Tag
mit kranken Kindern zu tun.
Nicht in allen Fällen
gibt es ein Happy End.
Ja logisch, tut einem das auch weh.
Ganz speziell ist es,
wenn die Kinder im gleichen Alter
sind wie die eigenen zu Hause.
Das macht noch mal
etwas anderes mit einem, aber ja.
Und was halt auch ist: Man
relativiert nachher wirklich Sachen.
Wenn man ganz schlimme Sachen sieht,
sagt man dann:
"Das, was wir zu Hause haben,
oder die Probleme,
das ist eigentlich gar nichts".
Leonard geht es im Moment recht gut.
So.
Wopp.
Es ist kurz vor 12 Uhr.
Am Brienzersee entsteht eine noble
Eigentums- und Feriensiedlung
mit eigenem Hafen.
Jedes Jahr werden in der Schweiz
etwa 50'000 neue Wohnungen gebaut.
Obwohl das Bevölkerungswachstum
zurückgeht, schätzt die UNO,
dass wir im Jahr 2050
die 10-Mio.-Grenze knacken werden.
Auf der einen Seite frage ich mich,
wo das alles hinführt.
Immer diese Wohnungen,
die gebaut werden usw.
Dabei liest man nachher
in den Medien,
wie viele Wohnungen leer stehen.
Ja.
Da frage ich mich manchmal schon,
wo es hinführt.
Denn irgendwann
macht es einfach bumm,
und nachher
ist es nicht mehr gut auf dem Bau.
Es geht gegen Mittag zu, aber
für Roger ist keine Pause in Sicht.
Jetzt ist eben das passiert,
was manchmal vorkommt:
dass es nicht nach Plan läuft,
dass die Lastwagen nicht kommen.
Jetzt bleibe ich oben.
Denn bis die beiden hier sind
und abgeladen haben,
ist schon bald wieder 13 Uhr
und dann kommt der Zimmermann.
Der will dann weiterfahren
mit seinen Elementchen.
(Mann über Funk) Willst du nicht
Mittagspause machen, Roger?
Nein, keine Zeit. Ich muss ja
nachher für den Zimmermann fahren.
Glücklicherweise hat er sich vorher
zwei Sandwiches gekauft.
Roger fühlt sich extrem wohl
in der Schweiz.
Ich bin hier aufgewachsen,
hier gross geworden.
Ich habe schon viel erlebt.
Ich möchte jetzt gar nicht weg
oder an einen anderen Ort hinziehen,
auswandern oder so.
Mir gefällt es hier.
Und ausserdem
bin eh nicht der Ausland-Typ.
Ich bin ein richtiger Nesthocker.
Zu Hause fühle ich mich am wohlsten
und hier bin ich am liebsten.
Denise hat's auf 12.30 Uhr
nach Hause geschafft.
Hallo.
Ich sehe gerade Jasmines Jacke.
Also sollte sie sich
irgendwo verkrochen haben.
Hier ist sie ja.
Sagst du nichts?
- Ich sagte Hallo.
Wirklich? Hab dich nicht gehört.
Jasmine hat gerade
mit der Lehrstellensuche begonnen.
Ich gehe nächste Woche als Klein-
motorradmechanikerin schnuppern
und nachher gehe ich noch
in einer Kita schnuppern.
Ich hoffe, dass sie sich entscheiden
kann, was sie werden will.
Mir ist wichtig,
dass sie etwas machen kann,
das sie gerne macht.
Etwas Handwerkliches oder so
ist immer spannend,
aber ihr muss es gefallen,
das ist das Wichtigste.
Also, guten Appetit.
- Guten Appetit.
Wichtig ist ihr auch, dass man in
der Familie alles diskutieren kann.
Ich fände es schön,
wenn sie wüssten,
dass sie immer kommen können
mit ihren Anliegen und Sorgen
und dass wir für sie da sind
und sie in allem unterstützen.
Das Wissen, dass sie
die Familie im Rücken haben,
das ist schon etwas Schönes.
Nach Dienstschluss ist Canad
unterwegs für seinen Verein.
Diesen hat er gegründet,
nachdem ein Arzt und alter Freund
aus dem Waisenhaus ihn gebeten hatte,
Medikamente nach Somalia zu schicken.
Eines der grossen Probleme in Somalia
ist immer noch
die Beschneidung von Frauen.
Die Leute beginnen zu verstehen.
Es gibt einen Mentalitätswandel.
Die Eltern, v.a. die Mütter,
haben ihre Töchter verstümmelt,
damit sie
gesellschaftlich akzeptiert werden
und damit Männer sie heiraten.
Heute wollen Männer
keine verstümmelten Frauen mehr.
Also sind die Eltern
jetzt gezwungen,
die Töchter
nicht mehr zu verstümmeln,
weil sie sonst
keinen Mann mehr finden.
Das trifft vielleicht
für urbane Gebiete zu.
Aber in Somalia werden immer noch
98 % der jungen Frauen beschnitten.
Das ist mehr
als überall sonst auf der Welt.
Das Medikament Solcogyn
lindert Schmerzen und Entzündungen.
Die Apothekerin Isabella Sollberger
hat sich bereit erklärt,
Canad das Medikament
zum Selbstkostenpreis zu verkaufen.
Diesmal - wie auch letztes Mal -
gehe ich persönlich.
Ich werde alles dokumentieren
und ich werde da bleiben,
bis die letzte Packung verteilt ist,
oder zumindest die Hälfte.
Ich werde alles dokumentieren.
Bevor wir die Bestellung machen,
möchte ich wissen,
wie viele Sie brauchen.
Es wäre dumm,
ihnen Medikamente zu liefern,
die sie nicht benutzen.
Also ... Solcogyn ...
- Ja, Solcogyn
Es wäre nicht ideal, verschiedene
Medikamente mitzubringen.
Man muss nicht
unnötige Bedürfnisse schaffen.
Man muss
auf präzise Fragen reagieren.
Wir müssen ja auch nicht 1'000
liefern, wenn sie nur 500 brauchen.
Nein, sie brauchen mehr als 500.
Ich sage 500, weil wir
nur so viel bezahlen können.
Voleva 100 confezioni da 100 pezzi.
- Sì.
Auch Maëlle hat einen Termin.
Sie muss den Siegelring
in La Chaux-de-Fonds abliefern.
Ohne Auto geht gar nichts.
Aber Maëlle
möchte um keinen Preis hier weg.
In dieser Region bin ich geboren,
aufgewachsen
und zur Schule gegangen.
Hier habe ich alle meine Freunde.
Die Familie, sie sind auch alle
in dieser Ecke zwischen
dem Val-de-Ruz und Neuchâtel.
Alle Menschen,
die ich liebe, wohnen hier.
Darum bin ich geblieben.
So ganz hat sie sich noch nicht
an ihre Selbstständigkeit gewöhnt.
Es gibt immer ein wenig Stress,
ob man alles richtig gemacht hat,
ob man nichts vergessen hat.
Das gehört dazu.
Aber es ist kein negativer Stress.
Ich kann es einfach kaum erwarten,
ihre Meinung zu hören.
Die Schmuckdesignerin Olivia
Jeanrenaud hat ihr Atelier zu Hause.
Sie hat schon ein paar Schmuckstücke
bei Maëlle bestellt
und ist für diese
eine wichtige Auftraggeberin.
(Französisch)
* Sie lacht zufrieden. *
Maëlle ist erleichtert.
Sie hofft auf weitere Aufträge,
denn die Konkurrenz schläft nicht.
Graveure hat es wegen
der Uhrenindustrie in der Gegend
mehr als genug.
Allein im Kanton Neuenburg
wurden in der Branche
in den letzten zwei Jahren
fast 500 Stellen abgebaut.
Wir gehören zu einer Generation,
die vielleicht
alle zehn Jahre arbeitslos wird.
Es ist so,
aber es ist nicht so schlimm.
Für mich war die Arbeitslosigkeit
auch ein Sprungbrett.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass ich ohne Arbeitslosigkeit
selbstständig geworden wäre.
Yes?
- Oui. J'espère qu'il sera content.
Good job.
Zurück im Tessin.
Canad ist auf dem Weg zur Moschee.
Vier Moscheen gibt es im Kanton,
235 in der ganzen Schweiz.
Meine Religion
hat mich immer geführt.
Jeder hat seine eigene.
Du bist z.B. Christ
und du übst deine Religion aus.
Ich bin Moslem
und ich übe meine Religion aus.
Daher gehe ich in die Moschee,
für das islamische Freitagsgebet.
Wie ihr sehen könnt,
hat die Moschee kein Minarett.
Es ist nicht obligatorisch
für unsere Religion.
Solange ich sie frei ausüben kann,
bin ich zufrieden.
Ich verlange nicht viel.
Im Industriegebiet von Giubiasco
beten regelmässig
etwa 200 Muslime aus der Region.
Canad findet es unangenehm, dass jede
Moschee momentan im Verdacht steht,
eine Terrorzelle zu sein.
Ich kenne die Leute nicht.
Ich weiss nur,
dass sie Muslime sind.
Sie kommen aus der ganzen Welt.
Es hat Schweizer, Italiener,
Pakistaner, Somalier, Eritreer,
Äthiopier, Algerier,
Marokkaner, Tunesier,
Muslime aus dem Balkan
und aus der Türkei.
Das sind ihre Staatsangehörigkeiten,
aber ihre Religion ist der Islam,
darum sind sie da.
Sie sind nicht da,
um Leute zu treffen.
Sie wollen nur
ihre Religion ausüben,
nicht quatschen oder etwas anderes.
(Muezzin) Allahu akbar.
Ungefähr 350'000 über 15-jährige
Muslime leben in der Schweiz.
Das ist knapp 5 % der Bevölkerung
und weniger als halb so viel, wie
in Umfragen jeweils geschätzt wird.
Es ist 16 Uhr.
Denise besucht
die zehnjährige Amelie.
Hey, es ist bald fertig, gell?
- Ja.
Mit sechs Jahren musste das Mädchen
erstmals operiert werden,
weil es
zwei ungleich lange Beine hat.
Sie hat
eine Beinverlängerung bekommen.
D.h., man hat mit diesem Gestell
das Knochenwachstum so angeregt,
dass das Bein länger geworden ist.
Gehen wir das Bein abduschen?
Denise hilft beim Waschen und schaut,
dass es keine Infektionen gibt.
Wie geht es,
wenn du den Fuss abstellst?
Gut, heute bin ich
ohne Krücken in die Migros gegangen.
Cool.
Sind wir fertig?
- Ja.
Die beiden kennen sich
schon seit der ersten Operation.
Sie ist lieb. Sehr.
Da bin ich schon noch froh.
Amelie ist
verhältnismässig selbstständig,
im Gegensatz
zu anderen kleinen Patienten.
Das ist eine Riesenbelastung
für eine Familie.
Und wenn wir dort nur schon
gewisse Zeiten abdecken können,
wenn es nur ist, dass wir
am Morgen ein Kind aufnehmen,
es anziehen und in den Rollstuhl
setzen oder was auch immer,
ist das eine Riesenunterstützung.
Denn die meisten
haben ja noch andere Kinder,
und die kommen ja sowieso
schon immer zu kurz.
Ich denke, es ist für die
betroffenen Eltern sehr schwierig,
und darum sind sie auch
sehr dankbar, wenn wir kommen.
Es ist 16.30 Uhr.
Für mich ist für heute Feierabend.
Ich freue mich schon,
dass ich nach Hause kann,
aber ich freue mich auch,
wenn ich morgen wiederkommen kann.
10 Std. lang war er auf seinem Kran.
Eine Toilette
hat er da oben natürlich nicht.
Als Kranführer
muss man sich zu helfen wissen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Canad ist früh aufgestanden.
Endlich zu Hause angekommen,
will er nur noch eins: schlafen.
Ciao. Ich bin müde.
Das ist mein Mittag- und Abendessen,
und ich muss
so schnell wie möglich ins Bett.
Morgen ist ein neuer Arbeitstag.
Auf Wiedersehen!
Es ist 17.30 Uhr.
Maëlles Partner Sam
ist von der Arbeit zurück.
Er ist Maler.
Zeit für ein Feierabendbier.
Die beiden
sind ein eingespieltes Team.
Ah, mais c'est trop bien.
Wir haben uns 2002 bei der Gay Pride
in Neuchâtel kennengelernt.
Und schlimmer noch:
Es war ein One-Night-Stand,
der schiefgelaufen ist anscheinend,
denn jetzt sind wir -
was? - 16 Jahre zusammen.
Ja, und wir haben uns
seit 16 Jahren nicht mehr verlassen.
Es war ein schönes Treffen,
völlig unerwartet.
Ja, wirklich:
"Geh zur Gay-Pride-Party
und lerne die Liebe deines Lebens
kennen!" Nein, es ist cool.
Kinderkriegen
war für sie nie ein Thema.
Es war von Anfang an ziemlich klar,
dass wir keine Kinder wollten.
Wenn wir mal ein Kind wollen,
kümmern wir uns
um die Kinder der anderen.
Wir haben zusammen ... neun Nichten
und einen Neffen. Also ist es okay.
Auch Roger
hat's nach Hause geschafft.
Vor einem halben Jahr
ist er mit seiner Familie
nach Thun in diese
Genossenschaftssiedlung gezogen.
Etwa 5 % aller Wohnungen
in der Schweiz
sind Genossenschaftswohnungen.
Da Rogers Frau nicht arbeitet
und er kein Spitzenverdiener ist,
ist die Familie
auf günstigen Wohnraum angewiesen.
Hallo zusammen.
- (Frau) Hallo, Papi.
Hallo.
- Hallo
Hallo, Larissa.
Hallo, Leandro.
- Hallo.
Er muss löschen.
- Musst du löschen?
Löschen und betonieren.
- Aha. Potztausend.
Jetzt können wir essen.
Roger versucht,
seinen Kindern alles zu geben,
was er selbst vermisst hat.
V.a. Geborgenheit und Zeit.
Leistungsdruck möchte er ihnen
eigentlich lieber ersparen.
Es wird sicher schwieriger,
es wird immer noch mehr
von einem erwartet,
man muss immer noch mehr leisten ...
Das fängt ja heute schon
bei den Kleinen in der Schule
und im Kindergarten an -
was die alles leisten müssen.
Ich finde es ein bisschen traurig
für die Kinder, für die Generation,
die das alles erleben muss.
Auch am Bielersee gibt's Abendessen.
Denises Partner Stefan hat gekocht.
Sind die Kinder auch ready?
- Kinder, Essen!
Denises Ziel wäre, einmal am Tag alle
zusammen an den Tisch zu kriegen,
aber immer schaffen sie es nicht.
Das gemeinsame Abendessen
ist für mich sehr wertvoll,
denn das sind die Momente,
die man jetzt noch geniessen muss.
Denn irgendwann
sind dann die Kinder ausgeflogen.
Ich denke,
das muss man schon schätzen,
solange man es noch hat.
Gut, dadurch,
dass sie jetzt grösser sind,
sieht ihr Programm auch
anders aus, es ist halt einfach so.
Da geht man nicht mehr
mit den Eltern wandern.
Das ist uncool.
- Wandern ist sowieso uncool.
Ich glaube, loslassen
ist für jedes Mami schwierig.
Aber auch darin müssen wir wachsen.
Angefangen haben sie bereits mit
Loslassen: Sie schmieden Ferienpläne.
Ich möchte unbedingt noch in
den Norden, die Nordlichter sehen.
Das ist einer meiner Träume.
Ob das mit
oder ohne Kinder stattfindet,
ist noch nicht definiert.
- Das spielt auch keine Rolle.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Es wird Nacht in der Schweiz.
In Thun sind die Kinder im Bett.
Nicole und Roger
spielen oft noch Uno zusammen.
Ich finde das noch schön,
ein bisschen Zeit
miteinander zu verbringen,
anstatt dass jeder
in seiner Ecke sitzt.
Manchmal braucht es
gar nicht so viele Worte,
ein bisschen beieinander sein.
Wie haben sie sich kennengelernt?
Über das Internet.
Es hat uns auch so erwischt,
wir haben das beide nicht erwartet.
Also bei mir war es einfach so:
Aus lauter Langweile
wollte ich einfach mal schauen,
welche Leute dort unterwegs sind.
Nachher wurde ich blöd angemacht,
was das für ein Kran sei.
Ja, das hat mir gefallen,
das Riesending, das du hattest.
Ich hatte als Profilbild
ein Foto des Krans, von unten rauf.
Dann kam ein dummer Spruch,
und ich dachte:
"Das lasse ich jetzt nicht
auf mir sitzen."
Dann schrieb ich zurück,
so hat es angefangen.
Hin und her und hin und her.
Dann machten wir mal ab,
dass wir ins Kino gehen,
auch etwas Leckeres essen -
und wie es dann so läuft.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Ich kann machen, was ich will,
ich verliere immer.
Auch Maëlle und Sam
haben ihr Abendritual.
Sie treffen sich
meistens in der Küche.
Wir kochen gerne zusammen.
Wir erzählen uns von unserem Tag,
das ist cool. Das gefällt mir.
Ja, das ist ein kleiner besonderer
Moment zwischen uns beiden.
Und da wir gerne essen, verbringen
wir viel Zeit in der Küche.
Und nachts hier zu sein,
wir beide zusammen, das ist cool.
Die Umgebung, die Ruhe,
ein bisschen Musik hören ...
Und niemand tanzt uns auf
den Füssen rum, das ist grossartig.
Morgen stehen sie wieder auf.
Und mit ihnen 8 Mio. andere Menschen
in der Schweiz.
Jeder mit seinem Alltag,
mit seinen Wünschen und Träumen
und mit seiner
ganz persönlichen Geschichte.
SWISS TXT / UT-Redaktion Zürich
Jasmin La Micela - 2018